I'd like to start by sharing the latest
data if we could have the first slide
please
the first slide shows the information on
infections and the data published by the
Office for National Statistics this
morning shows that the number of people
who had corona virus in England fell
from around a hundred and thirty-nine
thousand
between the third and 16th of May to
around 53,000 between the 17th and 30th
of May and that's represented in
percentage terms in this right-hand
chart and it demonstrates that the
percentage of the population testing
positive has been falling consistently
over recent weeks
saij have confirmed that the are across
the whole of the UK is between 0.7 and
0.9 and the Office for National
Statistics survey also estimated the
number of new coronavirus infections
which sounds at 39,000 per week which is
equivalent to around 5600 per day and
this is lower than the similar estimate
made last week so these are encouraging
trends about the reducing spread of a
corona virus across the country next
slide please
this slide shows progress on testing and
the number of new confirmed cases in
total 5,200,000 tests have been carried
out including two hundred and seven
thousand two hundred and thirty-one
tests yesterday and these data on tests
include both the swab tests to find out
if you have corona virus and also the
antibody tests which standard around
just over 40,000 antibody tests a day
the antibody tests find out if you have
the virus and if you have had the virus
then you can help make a difference
because by donating your plasma from
your blood that has your antibodies in
it then you can help somebody who is
currently suffering in hospital with
corona virus I did this earlier today I
gave my antibodies and the process is
simple its straightforward if you have
had corona virus if you go to the NHS
Blood and transplant website NHS BT then
you too can donate your antibodies and
help protect somebody who's currently in
hospital with corona virus and I'd
encourage anybody who can do that to
step forward the chart also shows that
the number of confirmed cases is one
thousand six hundred and fifty yesterday
which brings the total number of
confirmed cases confirmed by positive
swab tests to two hundred and eighty
three thousand three hundred and eleven
next slide please
this slide shows the data from hospitals
there were six hundred and ninety four
admissions new admissions with kovat 19
on the latest data which has fallen over
the last week those data include England
Wales and Northern Ireland that don't
include Scotland and also the the bottom
data which is across the whole UK shows
the number of people in mentem in
ventilator beds has fallen from 751 on
the 28th of May a week ago down to 571
and this is down from a peak of over
3000 on the 12th of April next slide
please
slide 4 shows the regional breakdown of
people in hospital and it shows that
over 7,000 people remain in hospital
7080 to be precise but this is down 15%
from 8,000 to
and 85 a week ago and a peak of over
20,000 in April the final slide next
slide please
shows the number of people who have
sadly lost their lives and this number
stands at forty thousand two hundred and
sixty one on the latest information
which is three hundred and fifty seven
higher than yesterday
and these slides demonstrate that
although that the past few months have
been a time of sorrow for so many people
because each of these deaths is not a
statistic but the loss of a loved one
for so many families the slides also
show that we have made a progress in our
fight against the virus but they also
show that there's so much more to do
thank you
it shows that we must always remain
vigilant especially when it comes to
protecting our NHS which has been at the
frontline of the battle and of course
thanks to an enormous national effort we
protected the NHS and prevented it being
overwhelmed which in turn saved lives
and today I want to set out further
steps that we're taking to protect the
NHS and especially around face coverings
and face masks yesterday the secretary
State for Transport announced that face
coverings will become mandatory on
public transport from the 15th of June
with a few specific exceptions for
instance those with breathing
difficulties
this doesn't mean surgical masks which
need to be kept for clinical settings
but the kind of face masks that you can
easily make at home and in fact there's
a good guide on gov you K as more people
go back to work and the passenger
numbers start to increase so face
coverings on transport become more
important likewise as the NHS reopens
right across the country it's critically
important to stop the spread amongst
staff patients and visitors to
so today we're setting out that all
hospital visitors and outpatients will
need to wear face coverings one of the
things that we've learned is that those
in hospital those who are working in
hospital are more likely to catch corona
virus whether they work in a clinical
setting or not and so to offer even
greater protection we're also providing
new guidance for NHS staff in England
which will come into force again on the
15th of June and all hospital staff will
be required to wear type 1 or 2 surgical
masks and this will cover all staff
working in hospital it'll apply at all
times not just when they're doing the
life-saving work on the frontline it'll
apply in all areas except those areas
designated as covert secure workplaces
and of course where the PPE guidance
recommends more stringent protection of
course that remains in place we're
upgrading this guidance to make sure
that even as the virus comes under
control and as we saw the falling
incidence across the country hospitals
are a place of care and of safety
we've also strengthened infection
control in care homes and we're working
with the social care sector on how this
approach can apply appropriately in
social care - it's about protecting the
NHS and social care which means
protecting our colleagues who work in
the NHS and in social care and I want to
say this to all my colleagues in health
and social care as we get this virus
under control it is so important that we
stamp out new infections and outbreaks
and of course in health and care you do
this brilliantly all the time and
coronavirus is no exception
that means that if one of your team
tests positive you have to follow the
isolation advice the natural impulse of
course of anybody who works in care in
the NHS
is the the thing you can best do is be
there to help to be there for their
patient but of course if you have the
virus or our risk of having the virus
the best thing that you can do for them
as well as yourself is to isolate at
home and this means that social
distancing in the workplace also must be
reiterated and it matters just as much
as anywhere else and I know that social
distancing and self isolation can cause
big logistical challenges and will
support you in doing what is right and
necessary all of us have a role to play
here and the last thing I want to say is
this that ahead of this weekend when I
know that there are plans for further
protests I want to say something to you
as health secretary like so many I'm
appalled by the death of George Floyd
and I understand why people are deeply
upset but we're still facing a health
crisis and coronavirus remains a real
threat and the reason that it's vital
that people stick to the rules this
weekend is to protect themselves and
their family from this horrific disease
so please for the safety of your loved
ones do not attend large gatherings
including demonstrations of more than 6
people we all need to stay alert control
the virus and save lives